thank you Karen Karen was the is the
puppet master of this whole series of
events so we said one more round of
applause for Kanye and my name is David
hey do I'm the ringleader timekeeper and
holder of the hook for the next hour I
don't have I won't be contributing that
much myself i'll just try to keep things
moving along I'm going to I teach here
at Columbia I teach the Graduate School
of Journalism I teach a seminar on arts
and culture I've written quite a bit
about comics too I wrote a book called
the Tencent plague which relevant to
this discussion has to do with the
relation oh thank you the relationship
between between comics and politics in
this case the tents of like has less to
do with politics in comics than it has
to do with comics in American politics
that's a little cryptic the price of
curiosity is sixteen dollars son
introduce the members of the panel in
alphabetical order so as to not impose a
hierarchy or to gender this John Kerry
is in second here too from my left the
editorial cartoonist for the greater
media newspaper is a group of 10 weekly
newspapers in New Jersey he's a painter
and an arts educator and exhibiting
artists since 1979 he said 19 one-man
shows here and abroad and has
participated in numerous group
exhibitions he's been the recipient of
various grants including grants from the
Pollack krasna foundation and Jodi dodge
foundation he's terrific Sabrina Jones
let's see there we go present is the
longtime editor and contributor to world
war three illustrated long-running
journal of political comics her books
include a graphic biography of Isadora
Duncan FDR in the New Deal for beginners
and she contributes to Wobblies Studs
Terkel working
yiddish kite and the real cost of prison
she's currently working on a graphic
adaptation of race to incarcerate which
if you haven't read it as a terrific
book like Mark Mauer Dennis kitchen all
the way in my left your right is a
pioneering underground cartoonists whose
company kitchen sink press cleverly
named published our crumb rubber crumb
will eisner harvey kurtzman Spiegelman
charles burns and many others of them
myself in 86 kitchen founded the comic
book Legal Defense Fund nonprofit
organization defending the comics
industry yes and we don't even have an
applause sign this is just great in
addition dennis is co-written books on
Kurtzman and underground comics for
abrams he curates our exhibitions and is
currently at work on relevantly on a
biography of al cab peter cooper to my
immediate left is co-founder of world
war three LZ SP google co-founder of
world war three illustrator and he's
drawn spy vs spy for Mad Magazine for
the past 16 years his graphic novels
include the system sticks and stones and
stop forgetting to remember and he's
also published the sketchbook Diaries
diario de ox sucks yes Anton tomorrow as
well as graphic adaptations of upton
sinclair's the jungle and Kafka's the
metamorphosis he teaches comics courses
at the school for visual arts in Harvard
now what we're not going to do here
today is present the capsule history of
politics in comics and cartooning we're
not going to present a 45-minute survey
instead we're going to look at the some
issues and themes and some and some
questions about the relationship between
comics and politics those two great
outlets for you
thrills and the grotesque in American
culture first I want to throw out a
couple questions as foundations for the
discussion i'm going to throw these out
to anyone on the panel feels like feed
and fielding them some foundational
questions about the relationship between
comics and and politics i think we
should start by asking why comics what
is it about comics what do comics do
uniquely that makes them suitable to the
subject of politics or ill suited to the
subjects of comic comic of politics what
the comics have that other forms of
communication other arts don't have that
make them suitable to this subject
anyone John I think that the comics are
you gonna ask I'm say this one move the
mic close to you and project you I think
comics are uniquely democratic you tell
somebody you're a painter and they say
Oh what kind of work modern and used to
tell somebody that you're you're a
cartoonist they're out there eyes light
up it's a very democratic medium and I
more people seeing my comics copy in one
week in the ten newspapers I I'm in then
in my whole history of painting pictures
so it's very universal medium okay and I
think that democracy extends also to the
fact that an artist can self-publish
something and get it out there and that
I mean it certainly was true when when I
was starting that you would be able to
photocopy and and just self distribute
and it's and it's been true with it with
the form in general that it's been
considered a low art but that is
actually meant that a large number of
people will see it and enjoy it identify
with
the form and now that was true with the
early comic strips and it's still true
today yeah very much want a second what
John said having moved from painting
into comics myself and that it's
definitely more accessible and a
disarming medium people do have that
reaction they think it's going to be fun
they don't think they have to know
anything to understand it so it
definitely opens a lot of doors and I'd
say ask boss tweed
it's it's great because it's an
instantaneous medium especially in
editorial cartoon get that quick impact
but even in comics and graphic novels
you kind of lure people in with the
pictures and then hit him with the
message and you know in the we know
today people have lost some less time to
read those thick tomes and so the words
and pictures combination is ideally
suited to a political message well how
my comics be not so well suited are
there any limits in your minds to the
capacity of comics to do justice to
politics for instance does it's absorb
comics appeal to youth or its absorption
with youth kind of make set up any
limits to the way comics could handle
politics well since I've written mostly
for adults I'm constantly frustrated
when people want to want to give them to
their children so it can be frustrating
that way we haven't gotten beyond that
idea that this is kid stuff but we do
know that if kids do read your stuff
that is definitely the earlier you get
them the easier it is to indoctrinate
them yeah yeah that is certainly an old
trope about comics of comics just hunt
for kids anymore how many articles have
had that headline I've written eight of
them so the format will be we're going
to hear from each one of the panelists
individually for a while and we're going
to start with with Dennis and Dennis
let's start by discussing the seminal
figure in in the history of comics and
cartooning will eisner who was with whom
you worked and done and and who you knew
quite well in life well as as a literary
figure approached comics from a literary
point of view no I didn't he didn't
approach comics II didn't quote forgive
me approach politics too
thankfully or overtly he approached
politics could indirectly as poetically
as a literary figure does so where do
you see politics fitting into I zor's
work if at all well he occasionally was
overt in terms of New York City back in
nineteen sixty-five 1966 right after
Mayor Lindsay was elected I think the
first Republican a long time he did a
special five or six page comic insert
for the New York Herald Tribune magazine
and the villains in that one were
bureaucrats working under the a beam
administration so that was overt earlier
in the spirit you don't see much
politics although he did bring adult
Hitler into a strip I think six months
before we entered World War two he had
Hitler come to Central City which of
course is New York and Hitler tries to
impress Americans with what a good guy
he is and at the same time undermine us
and we'll shows him trying to infiltrate
various disenchanted minorities and keep
striking out because he finds out that
even though they're disenchanted there's
still loyal Americans and eventually
they in the spirit bring him around to
realize the error of his ways decides to
go back to Germany and reform and
of course his Nazi henchman kill him and
substitute a duplicate so so that was an
overt use and he actually brought back
Hitler in the very very end of the
spirit in 1952 in the outer space
segment where he has used the German
rocket science to make it to the moon
and and interestingly he is the
syndicate at the time thought it was
inappropriate to use Hitler so they had
will at the last minute change his
Hitler mustache to a handlebar mustache
and he became a Spaniard because we all
know Spain's rocket science was ahead of
the curve presence of Hitler and the
Spirit brings to mind Will's interest in
Jewish identity which flourished in his
graphic novels do want to speak to that
into the political content of of that
work sure as will begin doing his
graphic novels and they good part of
them are autobiographical some more more
obviously than others but he began to do
more and more work focusing on the
anti-semitism he experienced himself and
ultimately the last work he did was the
plot which was about the the protocol
protocols of the Elders of Zion thank
you which was his most polemic work ever
and at that point I think he figured
controversy didn't scare him in fact his
next project he had talked about doing
was a graphic novel version of the Quran
which would have been pretty dangerous
but he was pushing 90 and I figured
he he said come and get me at that point
so yeah it became increasingly a
political in that sense oh not that we
could do I think both days of this
symposium on the subject subject of will
and I don't mean to diss serve them by
moving on but I do want to ask about
harvey kurtzman another artist with whom
you've worked closely until a lot of
work for and we all know of Kurtzman as
the creator of mad of course and we all
think of mad as an important vehicle for
political parody in the 1960s on I'd
like to throw out the question of
whether that conception of Madison is a
fulfillment of Kurtzman's vision or a
rejection or denial even of Kurtzman's
vision what's the relationship between
the politics of the mad we think of as a
political magazine in the 60s and what
Kurtzman made well it's hard to say it
Harvey didn't usually address politics
overtly either as a as a satirist he
liked to stay above political allegiance
he was an observer I remember once
visiting and he was on the exercycle
watching the Jimmy Swaggart show and I
was talking to him and and he was
literally watching it and I said aren't
you switching channels Harvey and he
said no I'd like to see how the other
America lives and what they think
speaking for myself as a generation who
grew up in the 50s mad was
in hindsight very political at the time
we didn't think of it that way but but
mad was someone once put at a machine
gun attack on American culture and it
was at a time when in in the 50s things
were pretty straight and narrow and
institutions and leaders and teachers
and ministers were all very respected
and you're expected to take them at
their word i think what Harvey did with
mad was showed us the phone eNOS and
hypocrisy of just about everything in a
way that was very eye-opening and
liberating and I think that generation
that grew up with mad in the 50s in the
60s was the same generation then that
really protested the Vietnam War and
that whole whatever you want to call the
hippie generation they were schooled by
harvey kurtzman and it turned out to be
a politically subversive in a real way
how did he feel about how man had become
under Feldstein overtly politicized well
he never spoke much about Feldstein I
think you got to remember mad was
Harvey's baby and he hated to see what
became of it in some ways it became a
lot more successful under Feldstein it
reached its peak circulation then but
when we talk about mad I think seldom
put Feldstein in the same category as
you would Harvey I think Harvey was
proud of what he created in a way
ironically enough it became kind of an
American institution even though it was
empty institutional last thing I want to
ask you Dennis and it's hard for me to
even keep my keep my focus because I'm
still thinking about one of the most
stunning things I've heard in many many
years which is the fact that harvey
kurtzman exercised
I as her unshakable but moving on Al
Capp you're writing about Al Capp yeah
just finished programming and we've
fairly think of cap as someone other
than reactionary right wing nutjob well
in his later years he was yes but you
have to remember for the the bulk of his
career in life he was actually a
Roosevelt Democrat and quite progressive
if those of you remember general bull
moose he epitomized the worst aspects of
capitalism and cap really was in many
ways a social progressive and he was an
early feminist he did a lot of things
that might surprise you but around the
mid 60s he did a real 180 degree turn
and he did become not just conservative
but pretty pretty seriously conservative
and and some of his closest friends
became Richard Nixon Spiro Agnew William
F Buckley and he became you know he was
always much more than any other
cartoonist he was a public figure
because he was on The Tonight Show
regularly and all kinds of shows he had
his own TV shows several times he had a
newspaper column a radio spot he was
everywhere it's hard to believe he's
largely forgotten now to a larger
generation but he was huge in the
culture so when he switched his politics
was pretty serious and remember his
strip was read at its height by about 90
million people a day so he had quite an
audience I don't think though that he
was his best as a satirist when he
turned to the right although he did make
some points and I can tell you in a
personal level and I was about 20 years
old in college part of that long-haired
Vietnam protesting crowd that he
abhorred he did a parody called Joanie
phony at a time when Joan Baez was at
her
I and he drew this folk singer who had
she's very homely she had no talent and
flies buzzing around her head because
she didn't bathe and of course the
reporters caught up with Joan Baez and
they said what do you think about what
El Cap is doing to you and she said she
abhorred it she thought it was awful and
she was talking to her lawyer and of
course cap had set her up because when
the reporters came to him he said he
said first of all he said I'm surprised
that Miss baes finds any similarity
between himself and my character but the
real set up line was he said he said
she's a professional protest singer and
she is in a protest movement and yet
when I protest she calls her lawyers and
he pointed out something that was
important which is you know the left
doesn't own satire and so occasionally
scored points but for the most part yeah
he became very borscht and not funny and
not I think a very successful satirist
because politics over road everything
and when he was successful the politics
were not obvious well for the sake of
fairness we're going to move on to Peter
and I'm going to need a little help from
Karen if you could come up here and
Peter's going to take the podium Peter
the podium is yours
blue I was asked to bring five or six
slides I brought 53 but I go through
them very quickly and I know that I'll
get the hook if I don't when I I first
came to New York when I was nine and I
was immediately taken with it but it had
this image of New York it's this big
kind of beautiful exciting place more
more of the kind of Frank Sinatra new
york new york song and when I moved to
New York in 1977 it was more like well
you get the lights down you could tell
but and that you know there was there
was the dramatic distance between what I
how I envisioned new york and how it was
in certain ways but then i came to love
that new york too but the version of
sinatra song came out more like this
with start spreading the news
I want to wake up in the city that
doesn't sleep to find I'm king of the
hill top of the heap if I can make it
there I'd make it anywhere but that
became the New York that I loved and I
still hear that music playing actually
am in the best sense so when I was in
art school this was an important figure
if you can tell it's Ronald Reagan and
he inspired the the magazine that i
co-founded with Seth to Bachmann and he
inspired the title too because the idea
that there was going to be this D actor
with his finger on the button and what
we found at first were whereas we were
talking about world issues very quickly
we realized that what we could talk
about was what was much closer to our
home right outside our door in fact and
that that kind of information was
something that would really matter to
talk about that's history also and we
weren't just talking about things that
we saw in the paper but but what things
that we experienced firsthand thank you
very much and we kept on finding things
to talk about and some of them did tie
directly into world issues but more
people started to be involved in the
magazine it always it never was just a
vanity press it was always about trying
to capture work that we saw on the
streets that would be on a lamp post one
day and then after the first rain would
be gone and that we felt that that was
history too and was being ignored in the
mainstream and we wanted to well we
actually we had very much wanted to join
in on the underground comix movement but
unfortunately all the head shops had
been closed down and the form of
distribution that came with that
disappeared but coming out of fans een
culture and self-publishing it wasn't a
crazy idea just to do a magazine and
that idea was not crazy to a lot of
people and so more and more people like
Sabrina Jones participated in editing
and publishing the magazine year
a year we are now celebrating our 32nd
year of publication and the secret to
our success we've never made a dime I
know it doesn't sound like a paradigm
for for work but it actually is a no
joke the the way you get something like
this to survive because as soon as
money's involved that means somebody has
to write a check somebody has to be a
business person who gets the money where
does it go we're free and clear of all
those questions but it was also a place
where we could have a communication and
talk about what kind of comics we were
doing and discussed the politics and
that led me to do something like the
system which I amazingly ended up being
able to do for DC vertigo which had many
of the same kind of concepts that I was
addressing in World War three how how
money passes from hand to hand for
example but then it was in this mortar
mainstream venue come September 11th i
found that comics was and world war
three in particular was a great place I
I was especially aware of how important
it was to have alternative media because
it was a time when there was a real
shutdown in what you could say and where
you could find a place to print it and
it was also a real a time of real
frustration over how limited art seemed
doing political art just seemed like
okay great i can do these drawings i can
express these things but is it changing
anything I can't stop the buildings from
coming down however actually I found
that in this case my daughters are was
extremely helpful because I'd come home
at the end of the day and I just kind of
enter her a little art world and it was
an exit from my not so pleasant real
world and so we in within three months
we had an issue of world war three out
we were used to selling about 2,500
copies and having mostly contributors
come to our meetings to the release
party when this came out 300 people came
and then we started having a lot of
people who normally weren't coming to us
to get their work published like Art
Spiegelman who would who weren't who are
having trouble publishing the ideas that
they were doing in mainstream venues and
that that's
and I truly understood how important it
is to keep maintain something like this
so after six years of George Bush I i
thought i did want to get a little break
from New York and we decided to my wife
and I decided to move to Mexico and get
away I thought it would be nice to get a
break from politics in general I wanted
to try some different kind of art we
arrived in the town of Oaxaca Mexico in
2006 the day we arrived the elections
the national elections had happened and
it apparently had been stolen there was
a teacher strike going on and it blew up
into a about 25 people were killed
including an American journalist named
Brad will who we published in World War
3 and suddenly there were federal troops
there and I had to face the fact that
there was no escaping politics but I
also realized I really wasn't looking
for an escape from politics I just
wanted different politics so this was
life around the time these are photos I
took after the federal troops came they
written on their shields it says sssc
nose which means murderers that a couple
of women had boldly walked up and wrote
I kept waiting for him to rearrange
their shields so it said have a nice day
one of the things I discovered there and
the reason why I've slipped this in here
is B is how art played a role in the
process of in the politics there it was
part of daily life especially during day
of the dead that the way art was used by
so many different people sometimes it
was the flag that was part of the charge
sometimes it was it was on a connection
to their history and I did see how in a
very real way in daily life and across
cultural and and financial levels that
people have different you know from from
workers to the museum's that their art
was playing a role but I did really
discover how small the world it was by
through this experience and
coming back to New York just realize
that the problem the problems and the
things that happened in in Mexico and
South America and Europe are directly
affect affecting what's happening right
here in New York and that it's it's one
giant connection and you know the the
rising tides or the tsunami in Japan and
you know the fallout from those things
they're all one giant connection no big
surprise it's a small world and so and
I'm seeing the connection between all
these things more and more as the tide
rises in Venice it too will rise in
lower Manhattan and as things are
happening now that will potentially be
the movement that we've been hoping for
for a while that will directly impact on
taking a stand and hopefully changing
the direction that we've been going I
really am seeing how our and humor can
play into politics and how important it
is to have that element in there and I
mean it's one of the things that I
noticed so much of the Occupy Wall
Street movement is how much humor is
there and and you know this is this is
one of the things that we as artists can
bring to it writers and all of us and it
was and how and how democratic of a
movement is there's a piece that Seth to
Bachmann from world war three did and
that in fact I noticed how little art
there was in the first round of it and
that I encouraged my students to go down
there and be involved artistically
there's now an Occupy Wall Street comic
that just came out the the the one of
the protests was at Foley Square which
by the way was the same Foley Square
where I believe they had the Senate
subcommittee hearings I thought it was a
nice dovetailing there so as the history
of these things go on we're just all
walking in a line of doing political art
that is part of a movement and although
the revolution may not be televised I do
suspect that it will be illustrated
thank you very much Peter I'm going to
bring up sabrina jones sam just try to
find her image is sabrina the floor is
yours okay that's me oh you're gonna
stay there and do come up would you mind
coming up okay looks like my computer at
home kinda hey so I started working on
comics on the third issue of world war
three the one you saw that said captive
city with the skeleton between the
buildings so by that point we were all
living many of us were living in the
east village after art school and it was
definitely a response to the environment
and I was already a political artist so
it was it was these guys with their
comics that kind of Lord me from the
absolutely wrong medium for me of doing
theatrical performance art oh here i am
on stage but to to drawing pictures and
and writing with them so I your fault
this comic is something I did for world
war three way back remember 2009 obama
was inaugurated and there was that glow
of hope world war three decided that
instead of doing our usual fist shaking
at the powers that be we were going to
we were going to be positive we were to
think about everything that was possible
and we were going to do things that we
wanted to see so we had the issue that
was called what we want and i had been
doing some historic stuff so I I started
researching about this great character
Jane Jacobs who I didn't know about
earlier but she was somebody whose ideas
just clicked right in with me in terms
of what makes a neighborhood a community
this is something we had been working on
with our you know neighborhood-based
politics in east village and she had
been someone who had her activism
had protected a lot of the kind of
neighborhoods that we love in New York
she led the charge against modernist
urban design and and defended the kind
of grassroots wisdom that creates
communities on a human scale so i did a
capsule biography of her and i did it in
a way that is very kind of world war
three where we had always done kind of
first-person narrative oh I framed it
with my own experience of neighborhood
so this is the the beginning of that
strip the first slide is actually a
color poster that was made by just seeds
which is now available based on the
content of this strip but in this trip I
kind of started out thinking about when
I first moved to the east village and
like most people I didn't move to New
York to live in a tenement on the Lower
East Side for 20 years it just happened
but you know I came here I I grew up in
Philadelphia I was like oh art museum's
the art world offs and soho you know but
real estate being what it is you know
that it was that glamour of the
metropolis that lures so many of us here
and that is what makes New York such a
great place full of you know bright
eager I'd people from all over so there
you see me rolling back from work into
the city thinking ah the metropolis the
big city bright lights big city it was
around the time of that book and I was
still young enough to do fun things
after work but then I would roll into my
neighborhood and it's like the small
city you know so this idea of the
dynamism of the big city at the economic
engine that attracts all kinds of people
all kinds of money and then that
intimacy that we still need of like this
is my neighborhood I feel comfortable
here with familiar landscapes and so
back a 10 years before that I want to go
back to a strip I did in the late 90s
and it's about a real heart of the
neighborhood where I was living in the
east side charas was a stew
I mean it was a community center where I
had a very precious thing cheap studio
space that allowed me to prolong my stay
in the city and so oh this is not the
this is the long version of the
slideshow oops but so I was I was
involved I was asked to do a strip for
world war three about the fact that this
community center which had been saved
from dereliction by a bunch of former
latino gang members in the late 70s was
and which was now a kind of a
multi-purpose community center with
people rehearsing and doing political
stuff and 12-step no it was now
threatened with eviction in the and the
turn of the sand in the 90s real estate
fever when Giuliani was saying we should
sell off all City own space and and just
take the cash and never mind the the
social value that's derived from people
using this so at the bottom you see that
it was empty in the 70s when the city
was was getting a little rundown when I
first arrived thriving in the 80s and
then this you know I ended this strip
with the panel where a where we're all
protesting and and scaring away the the
people who want to buy the building and
and it says this isn't real estate this
is a community center well it's no I
don't have a happy ending for that story
because we did get evicted in 2002 and
it was kind of a key to me leaving the
borough of Manhattan and and it's still
empty ten years later the building is
still empty there's nothing there sorry
to bum you all out so meanwhile out in
Brooklyn I one of my co editor's
contributors to world war three nicole
Schulman approached me with what was to
be my first entry into history in comics
she was co-editing with Paul Buell the
book about early labor historians and I
did a lot of different artists from
World War three were doing different
chapters in the history of the Wobblies
and I did this story about the pageant
of the Patterson strike which was a
situation where in 1913 these Greenwich
Village radical intellectuals hooked up
with striking silk mill workers in
Paterson New Jersey to help support
their strike to break the media blackout
that the bosses had arranged so it was
interesting you know as a villager
seeing the other sort of our our
great-grandfather's you know the radical
artists and intellectuals of the village
and how they had reached out with their
activism to create a theatrical event
that helped people know who were more
you know recent immigrants being
exploited in the mills across the river
so a couple of these characters I
introduced in here hey there we are back
on the Lower East Side John Reid the
radical revolutionary romantic is
rhapsodizing about what he discovers
there he came from the West and he was
kind of a adventurer revolutionary so I
used his words here and they echoed so
much my own excitement about strolling
around the city that sense of visiting
many worlds as you walk around the city
that would then lead him to great ends
as a what you call a participant
journalist and one of the people he met
he was not above and much as he loved
slumming it who's not above going to the
salons on Fifth Avenue where he met
Mabel dodge one of the people who
brought cubism to this country she had
just that year she had helped organize
the armory show that would shock the New
York art world with Marcel Duchamp but
she also met the people who were
organizing the mill workers and so there
was she threw her weight into organizing
this and getting support for it so you
see that i love that blending of the
the sort of artistic avant-garde with
the political avant-garde some couple
decades earlier now this is this is from
my graphic biography of Isadora Duncan
and I've got wrap it up in a minute
Isadora was was brought here initially
to raise money to get out of here
definitely an avant-garde artist not
always beloved in her native country but
one place she found a sort of bohemian
Haven was on was in New York hey here's
FDR that young man with the spectacles
in the middle would be the president one
day but at this point he was FDR he was
known and the social scene FD stood for
feather duster because he was such a
lightweight but his fiance was
volunteering and settlement houses on
the Lower East Side and she educated him
there in ways that would influence his
future politics New York angle he's a
new york boy whose policies would go
national and another New York bad boy
was governor Rockefeller who's infamous
drug laws would be this sort of
touchstone of the the race to
incarcerate and the the prison boom that
I'm working on now so this is sort of
the national scene that is inspired was
started in New York with the Rockefeller
drug laws created mass incarceration
which New York is now beginning to scale
back we are one of the few states to
actually reduce our prison population
don't forget to blame the Democrats too
it's not all Republicans Bill Clinton's
crime bill was one of the major major
builders of the mass incarceration and
because everybody gets bummed out when I
talk about prisons I wanted to end with
a little poetry Walt Whitman this is
going to appear in an anthology called
Bohemians
and Walt Whitman is communing with the
urban masses as he did talking about
that unique kind of sense you have of
wandering the city and feeling at one
with the crowd as he looked also at the
people on Brooklyn ferry and his
reflection in the water and he speaks to
the commuters of the future which would
be us that he's still watching over us
okay
thank you very huge Lee Sabrina and
finally we have John John Kerry John can
you come here oh okay all right I
thought I'd I thought I'd pay tribute to
some New Yorkers before I got to my
stuff and starting with Jules Feiffer
who was a presence for over 40 years on
page 4 in the village voice here's a
quote cartoonists are very different
from everybody else summer class clowns
or they did poorly in school or they
didn't get along with their families or
they'll it lies underground in hiding
from everybody else one way one way or
another they are weird and the only
pleasure they get is by drawing not all
cartoons are like that but an
extraordinary number of cartoonists are
exactly like that and I was among that
group so let's see him all right now
here's one he said he fight first
started doing anti-vietnam cartoons as
early as 1963 and here's one sorry
couldn't find a job join the army sent
the name three tours of duty came home
detested can't find a job and Misty for
draft dodgers and deserters that's cool
what about n masti for vets that's a big
serious question that this country was
not answering at the time all right
moving along I pledge allegiance to my
country seems like I should start with
well done it well I pledge allegiance to
my country the flag the church the
family the neighborhood
Rockwell Normandy standing tall standing
rich standing right standing white the
United Disney of America a little bit
before the United Disney at forty-second
Street came along you know there's a
Segway here from dennis's realize their
introduction to to fight for Pfeifer
showed up at eyes nurse studio and I
don't think eyes there was that keen on
on this young artist but when he found
out he was willing to work for nothing
he was he's really interesting and he
found out they found out fine for knew
everything about it collect the jonathan
schwartz with sinatra he knew everything
about this guy so that's going to say oh
yeah so fighter said I he hired me as a
groupie so alright one last one last
Pfeiffer here we go bush-era almost as
governor of Texas I have denied 98 stays
of execution in five years despite pleas
from human rights groups international
tribunals and the Pope himself I have
approved but more death sentence than
any governor in any state in the Union
no problem governor Bush but did you
ever use cocaine there's a two-pronged
attack Don John on our candidates and
our electoral process moving toward a
lot of people the op-ed page start in
1970 and for 13 years that art editor
was jerel Krause and there were so many
good artists it was a pleasure to open
that paper up and and one of the things
about reading the paper online now you
have to go to that article I see it you
can't you can't see it as part of the
composition of those two pages but David
Souter I all saw it was incredibly woody
fellow now how he I would love to have
seen the the brainstorming process to
get that bank image from that fork and
grill of that car I I don't know how he
got there but I love it that's great one
more when Brezhnev died I mean
terrific couldn't ask for better
marriage Richard Cyril who we lost
recently wondering what a life story
that man had but great stuff very very
very exciting stuff to see in in the
times you don't expect to see Ralph
Steadman and science with their youth
Rome Glaser they need of a glazier nice
stuff and David looking in theory of
evolution frankly my dear I don't give
us a damn all right Edward Sorrell I
think Liz about a stone's throw away
from here im not mistaken and what a
line and uh he takes us on a journey
with that line and you can I wrote him a
fan letter once and said it was like
listening to a great jazz solo you just
see it emerging you can see the history
of his hand it's a beautiful looping
loping gestural line and just terrific
stuff this was done just about the time
I came to New York City fall 1975 so the
question Americans must ask himself is
this if Washington could afford to
support organized corruption in Vietnam
why can't a sport organize crushin in
New York no no no Terry now listen
carefully first I nominate you for vice
president then after I resign you now
let me see if I had this right i pardon
you and then you give me honesty for
draft dodging and then I'm nominating
you for vice president and then I become
vice president right all right people
had fun with Ford all right why not
let's store a little excitement into
this let's throw a little excitement
into this the symposium those bandoliers
are always a dead giveaway but again
it's a isn't it great stuff I mean it's
that line work is just
when he when he was in his 40s he said I
realized that my my sketches were more
exciting than the finished product so he
let the process show all right Hoover
and Hitchens and even though this one's
a more polished piece an earlier work if
it hadn't been constructed with a
terrestrial line it wouldn't it wouldn't
have been that way you can still feel it
but he likes to let it he likes to let
it show now there's a beauty I love that
earth sliced up like a hand and that
waiter he really looks like eric
campbell from the Charlie Chaplin one
real is that that heavy beautiful
drawing ok Dancing with the Stars I he
leads and she spins I guess alright
finally my stuff here Republicans
Congress threatened to cut funding for
public broadcasting Grover regrets he
has but one life to give for PBS this
one was this one was made to order I
think that was one of the the big issues
of our of our time and the Reverend
Terry Jones what comes around goes
around unfortunately and still is now I
when I lived in the city car alarms were
worth the problem but now that I live
outside they've been slightly replaced
it seems like there's always one beefy
huge fellow Moving's six leaves across
his backyard for about 45 minutes
before he gets into this truck to go to
the gym okay current events Iran and the
GOP Family Circus okay now nudie nudie
thought he was on his way a while back
but the midi michelle and perry did not
really like that I really loved making
Perry the dog you know sometimes another
person's appreciation can make can
change your whole outlook on something I
never paid much attention to the Family
Circus I couldn't help but but not read
it but I found out Lynda Barry loved the
Family Circus because she didn't have a
family like that so from from then on I
ought appreciate it okay a rougher style
for a rougher topic and finally the
brilliant leader successfully creating
unity altering stereotypes and spreading
joy throughout the region no contest
right thanks very much
okay kid can we have the house lights
back on I don't know who does that
somebody do or put the light matches
just glow from within okay we have a few
minutes for questions oh you know let's
just have questions of the limited time
we have um okay we only we only have
about five minutes left so okay so if we
have questions from the audience I
should folks thep up to the microphone
there's a microphone here I'd ask you to
please step up and use the microphone if
you have a question and you could
address it to anyone on the panel or
someone in particular hey everybody my
name is Anthony shabam from New York
City yeah so I got a question Oh have
you read comic books while growing up
what was the question I'm sorry uh what
was your favorite comic book growing up
all right the question is what's your
favorite comic book anybody want to feel
that I started out with superheroes and
I moved into the underground comics and
so that I mean it was sort of the
natural line so yeah I mean spider-man
for sure and then later everything by
crumb and all the guys that were doing
like environmental comics and fabulous
furry freak brothers all that hmm all
right any other questions sir good feel
free did you ever have to do self
censorship in that you got caught up in
an anger or something and you sort of
emphasized maybe ethnic background maybe
got a little rough on on the image or is
that just something that this generation
doesn't have any connection to only when
I was doing a story based on another
person a friend of mine and I hadn't
asked her permission she asked me to
remove a sex scene and i honored her
wish
no if you know doing George Bush I you
know I tried to tone down the ethnic
references but ok we have another
question you miss thank you so much for
such an inspiring panel my question for
you is do you consider yourself
journalists I guess I'm a newspaper guy
I like to just because i think it is
kind of disappearing and and I and I add
today I add to that paper and I am an
editorial page so there's at that
connection with me I feel like I you
know I started as an artist so I'm still
there's a strong sense that that
everything I approach is with that kind
of sense of wanting to make it mine that
isn't necessarily what journalists do
but as I do nonfiction there's there
strands of journalism and strands of
historian that I'm definitely i still
want to be legit in those fields I don't
want to be seen as falsifying it even
though i'm presenting an opinionated
subjective version and right now I'm
adapting a book this rates to
incarcerate that's written by a very
it's a very well documented you know
look at social history and so I'm I have
the author to pull me back if I start to
go too far and over States something
because it's a very well researched
argument and i'm not being allowed to
you know do anything you know I have to
do my throw my flames in the pictures
not in the text because i've had people
will correct your text i've never been
copy edited on the picture except for
that friend with the sex scene but but
usually see that you can draw whatever
you want but they'll correct what you're
right
peter i would just said the journalists
have to be neutral by nature and
suppress their own feelings and i think
if you're a cartoonist and you do that
probably going to be boring pretty fast
they rewarded for being more
entertaining but at the same time you
are a journalist you're observing the
culture society kind of regurgitating it
back but you have to do it in an
entertaining way that it the journalists
usually can't one of the things that
really interests me about comics is as a
medium it's so wide open to all these
different areas you can do autobiography
you can do biography and journalism is
certainly an aspect of that that is just
beginning to be explored with people
like Joe Sacco in particular doing true
solid amazing journalism using comics
and they're highly entertaining even
though they're sometimes very straight
on and they're actually opinionated you
know I mean it's not like Keats he's
trying to cover the subject matter and
important you know in a clear way but I
just think that's an one of the areas
that comics can open up that has it so
it's only in its infancy that way I
think that's that's a perfect way to
wrap up because if you have more
interest in journalism you can come over
to the school where I teach and pay
sixty thousand dollars and we'll help
you out thank you very much for coming
thank you to this glorious panel for
doing this
you